le déjà fait l'école à la maison comme
tous les enfants fanny s'y est habituée
elle aussi sa maman lui fait cours tous
les jours ses camarades de grande
section de maternelle du manque bien sûr
mais la petite fille de 5 ans
paraplégique ne veux pas retourner en
classe à l'elysée pour attraper le virus
c'est la hantise de fanny et de la
famille les parents aimeraient aussi
savoir si l'auxiliaire de vie scolaire
qui accompagnent leurs filles pour être
à ses côtés
mais ils ont sondé leurs enfants et
décidé tous ensemble qu'il n'irait pas
panis en priorité on ne mettra pas à
l'école du à son handicap c'est quand
même un enfant qui est plus à risque les
autres donc on mettra pas non plus
morgane parce que le fait d'aller à
l'école elle que très bien emmené le
virus ou le ramener à la maison donc
pour l'instant on n'envisage pas de les
remettre à l'école pour cette
association la décision de retourner à
l'école appartient aux parents mais
auxiliaire de vie ou pas ne doit pas y
avoir de discrimination entre les
enfants
il n'y a pas de raison à ce que les
enfants en situation de handicap ne ne
rentre pas à l'école
eux aussi après il faut qu'il ait les
accompagnements nécessaires c'est à dire
qu'il faut que les aes h les auxiliaires
de vie scolaire puisse être présent donc
être présent et en nombre et qu'elle est
aussi les équipements nécessaires dans
l'yonne quelques 1300 élèves en
situation de handicap sont scolarisés en
milieu ordinaire
près de 700 ont besoin d'un
accompagnement à ce jour la plupart des
mairies ne savent toujours pas si elles
pourront garantir les conditions de leur
retour en classe